اكد جيش النيجر تمسكه بالاطاحه بالرئيس
محمد بازوم وتوعد بالتصدي للتدخل العسكري
الذي هددت مجموعه اكواس بتنفيذه وكان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
مدى جديه الخطه التي اعدتها اكواس للتدخل
العسكري في النيجر ما امكانيه استجابه
القاده العسكريين في النيجر للمهله
الممنوحه لهم كيف ستتعامل دول جوار النيجر
الاخرى مع خيار التدخل العسكري
مجموعه الكواس اتخذت قرارا متسرعا نوعا ما
لانه خطير جدا ومن الصعب
تطبيقه ومن الصعب ايضا الرجوع عنه في
الوقت الراهن فرنسا تواصل تبني موقف
متشدد ضد الانقلابيين
وهي تختفي وراء مجموعه الاقتصاديه للدول
الغربيه واذا لم تتمكن منا التدخل بعد
الاعتراض مجلس الشيوخ
النيجيري فان ذلك سيكون معقدا بالفعل لذلك
انا اعتقد بان
سيكون هناك تحضيرات عسكريه جديه
وتظهر بشكل يوحي بان التدخل احتمال التدخل
يبقى دائما قائما بالوقت الذي ينبغي ان
يكون فيه مفاوضات موازيه لها
تواصل شده الذراع في هذه المساله في
الوقت الراهن واستعراض العضلات من قبل
فرنسا
لانها لا يمكنها المواصله في هذا الموقف
المتشدد طويلا كانت الريحانات ان يكون
هناك جبهه داخليه وهذا لم يحصل او يحدث
هناك انقلاب ضد الانقلاب وهذا لم يحدث
التدخل العسكري نرى انها تتقلص يوما بعد
يوم لا اعتقد مره اخرى ان الامريكيين
والفرنسيين
[موسيقى]
سيغامرون في عمليه عسكريه دوليه بهذا
الشكل اذا مات راجعت مجموعه غرب افريقيا
فان فرنسا وامريكا ستتراجع
الجيش الانقلاب في النيجر وصل الى نقطه
اللانهايه وباعتبار ان الشعب التف حوله
يجد هذه الورقه
الرابحه في يدها كلما تحددت نيجيريا
واعوانها عن التدخل وحضروه شكل ذلك فعلا
ضغطا ولكنه بالمقابل يستخدمه الطرف الاخر
لتسجيل لتجييش مشاعر في الوطنيه لدى الناس
المحليين والسكان في النيجر اذا نحن امام
حكومتان كما حدث في فنزويلا ما الرئيس
مادورو في 2020 حيث الشعب اعترف به كرئيسا
للجمهوريه بينما دول الغربيه وخاصه
الولايات المتحده اعترفت بخوان جويدو الان
هذه الحاله بالتمام في جمهوريه النيجر
والاعتراف من قبل المجلس العسكري لا يزال
قائما
انا اعتقد بان
الانقلابيين فعلا
سيلجاون لاي طرب اخر عسكري
يساعدهم
ويلعبون على الوتيره السياسيه في صراع
سياسي العالمي للمنطقه بين من جهه روسيا
ومن جهه اخرى الولايات المتحده وهران لا
اعتقد ان
الانقلابيين يحتاجون الى مساعده فاغنر حتى
وان كان ذلك من ضمن اللعبه
سياسيه للتهديد لا اتصور مرتزقت فاجنر
يصلون الى نيجر وهم يعانون ضعفا اخر قويه
جدا وهو الحصار الاقتصادي النيجر يعتمد
كثيرا على
المساعدات الخارجيه وعلى العلاقات
الخارجيه اليوم وتحت حصار اقتصادي
اعتقد ان الانكلابيين كانت مخاوفهم منصبه
فيما يتعلق بالجاره نيجيريا وهي اكبر دوله
والدوره ايضا دوله قوه من حيث مؤشر القوه
العالميه قرر مجلس الشيوخ النيجيري الرفض
اطار تفويض للرئيس النيجيري بولاتي نوبل
للتدخل في جمهوريه النيجر
وحتان جريئه
وقوتها هي الاخرى تعاني اكراهات شديده لان
بها عدم استقرار الامن داخلي الحرب ضد
بوكو حرام والحرب حتى ضد الطوائف القبليه
فيما بينها وجيشها منها كل حد ما هنالك
كذلك موقف الدول
التي ليست من مجموعه افريقيا الغربيه مثل
ما موقف موريتانيا موقف الجزائر وموقف
التشاد التي تندد هذا الانقلاب ولكنها
ليست متفقه مع تدخل العسكري
الدول الاخرى كلها ليست معادله النيجر
وجموله لا يمكن ان تخاطر لوحدها او حتى ما
سنغال والساحل العاج الدول الحريسه جدا
على التدخل العسكري الحل الوسط الان
الدبلوماسي الممكن تنفيذه هو فتره
انتقاليه قصيره تكون ثلاثه اشهر او سته
اشهر على ان لا يرجع الحزب الحاكم السابق
او النظام السابق للحكم ولا يبقى
الانقلابيون في السلطه